where a lot of the uh your friends
family I know I saw some of the fans
were maybe a little worried that with
the situation that just happened at no
jumper that you your sobriety might have
been uh in question or or you might have
maybe gotten mentally hit by it or did
it did it bother you in that way were
you able to kind of get through it the I
was able to get through it by the grace
of God however I will say the closest
I've gotten to relapsing the only time I
was like considering it really
considering it was after Adam kicked me
out that day and I I was driving around
the valley you feel me like driving
around the valley not stopping because I
knew that if I stopped I was going to go
to a liquor store and get on and get
along get me a little bottle and get it
that day that day what was it that made
you what did you call you have a sponsor
I do have a sponsor and I call my
sponsor and like that was between him
that's dope and people that are close to
me they want to talk to me off the ledge
and I realized nah that's not how I want
to move but yeah no it was